the first Democratic presidential
debates of the 20/20 campaign begin
tomorrow 20 candidates will pack the
stage in South Florida across two nights
with so many candidates in one place we
wanted to see what Democratic voters in
a nearby state are thinking in our
original series 3 meals CBS News
contributor Steve Inskeep visited three
South Carolina cities to talk with
voters over breakfast lunch and dinner
we'll do this once a month around the
country during the campaign Steve also
hosts NPR's Morning Edition and up first
Steve where did you start your trip well
we started in Charleston which is one of
the state's largest cities now South
Carolina is one of the early primary
States that's why it's good to go there
it's heavily Republican but Democrats
have a voice in that primary so we took
a road trip and over three meals in one
day people told us what issues are most
important in their lives we had
breakfast at 7:30 at the marina variety
store restaurant how are you guys
connected to one another
Doug Warner is a veteran whose job now
is promoting this growing city the
concerns I have here are concerns that
he wants better roads and schools to
serve big new employers like Boeing the
other forces sealable right right we're
we're not below sea level like New
Orleans but we're Lowe's it's what they
call it the low country do people get
climate change around here Towson's
pretty progressive and he'd like a
progressive president but I want
somebody that can win against Donald
Trump
he likes Joe Biden who vacations near
this historic city in South Carolina
people live surrounded by the past out
here in Charleston Harbor is Fort Sumter
where the civil war started in 1861 a
little bit inland is a former slave Mart
that's now a museum and the black church
where a white man opened fire in 2015
killing nine people today South
Carolina's substantial black population
is a significant part of the Democratic
Party vote
at Hannibal's kitchen Tamara and Calvin
Baxter's say they love the historic
district when I'm down there I feel
inspired you feel inspired because wow
people came up from slavery and like
this is my people
around here but the Baxters census city
and nation divided racial divide no one
is really trying to come together today
make the country one now this tribe out
of Charleston is taking us out of the
low country by the coast and away from
one of the richest parts of South
Carolina our next destination is in one
of the poorest counties in this state
to Orangeburg South Carolina for lunch
at Aunt Lee's barbecue in this old farm
town we met a family who had just come
from a funeral
Shirley B Caldwell grew up nearby
picking cotton I went in the cotton
field her son Todd now works for a bank
economy is not the richest and for that
reason Jacquetta Chapman is interested
in Democrat Elizabeth Warren I love the
fact that she is an advocate for
eliminating student loans I didn't come
from a family with you know lots of
money that could just that could just
pay for my college education she's a
teacher still paying her student loans
while supporting college for her son
well Charleston where we started as a
port city and Orangeburg is in the
historic cotton growing part of South
Carolina
Spartanburg where we're headed now
through slow traffic he is historically
a textile city wild when you drive it's
attracted new industries like BMW
alongside older businesses like the
beacon drive-in owner Steve Duncan has
all the customers he can handle its kind
of hard yet Faye and John Smith are
troubled by the direction of the country
do you want someone to just steady the
ship or do you want someone to make a
big change I don't like this you want to
make a big change Cory Booker America we
know like I just see a lot of Obama in
here when Obama was campaign distaste
for president Trump causes her to rule
out the democratic women who were
running now that's a remarkable thing
we've had a black president but you
think America is still not ready for a
woman I don't think we're ready
so Democratic voters in this Republican
state know they have one shot to
influence the election it is in the
primary and some want to be sure that
they take that shot on a candidate who
can win I'm surprised to hear a comment
at the end I love that the person
sitting next to just kept right on
eating it's all in one day yes yes a
free meal Gail that's a power but it was
interesting to hear the variety of
opinions too yeah yeah there's a lot of
different people who are curious about
different candidates but they really are
focused on defeating President Trump we
should remember very conservative state
gonna vote Republican in the fall but in
the primary this subset of people who
are Democrats can have a big did you
have a favorite meal down there in South
Carolina oh my gosh the shark Nuggets at
the one my favorite thing that I've ever
eaten but it's notable terrific your
mouth I appreciate that all right I'll
take the recommendation he didn't keep
thank you very much